النظريات بشان سبب انهيار سدك خوفك في
جنوب اوكرانيا لكن لا احد يستطيع ان ينكر
تاثير ذلك على الامن الغذائي في المنطقه
وخارجها
تحذر منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه التابعه
للامم المتحده من ان تدمير السد سيؤثر على
الارجح على الامن الغذائي حيث غمرت المياه
الاف الهكتارات من الاراضي الزراعيه يعد
السد المهم على نهر النيفرو مصدرا رئيسيا
للري الزراعي في جنوب خرسون وشبه جزيره
القرم وقالت وزاره الزراعه الاوكرانيه انه
من المتوقع ان تغمر المياه نحو عشره الاف
هكتار من الاراضي الزراعيه على الضفه
الشماليه لنهر النيبرو في منطقه خرسون
وعلاوه على ذلك فان كارثه تدمير السد سوف
تعرقل وصول المياه الى شبكات ري الحقول في
مناطق
وخيرسون
الاضرار زراعه وتربيه المواشي وانتاج
الغذاء ما يهدد بكارثه انسانيه تعد
اوكرانيا رابعه
اكبر دوله مصدره للحبوب في العالم على
الجانب الاخر تقول موسكو ان الانفجار دمر
خط انابيب الامونيا وهي مكون رئيسي
للاسمده في منطقه
ما يعني الحاق الضرر ببنيه اساسيه ضروريه
لضمان الامن الغذائي في العالم حسب مقاله
المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا
واثار تدمير سدك خوفكا مخاوفه من شح
الامدادات بسبب التصعيد في الحرب بين
مصدري الحبوب الرئيسيين بعد تجدد التوتر
بشان اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب في البحر
الاسود
وتزود اوكرانيا وروسيا افريقيا باكثر من
اربعين في المئه من احتياجاتها من القمح
كان الحصار الذي تفرضه روسيا الموانئ
الاوكرانيه في البحر الاسود قد تسبب
بارتفاع اسعار السلع الغذائيه في العالم
وبحدوث نقص في بعض الدول التي تعد الافقر
في العالم وذكر خبراء برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي ان ازمه سد كخوفكا ستقوض الامن
الغذائي بثلاثمائه وخمسه واربعين مليون
شخص في العالم الذين تعتبر الحبوب القادمه
من اوكرانيا
بمثابه انقاذ لحياتهم